[Music]
ten
years 10 years i've been doing this
that's a long dang time
that is a quarter of my life
and i have no plans to stop
but given how long i've been doing this
i think it's probably safe to say
there's a fair amount of stuff on this
channel that a lot of people have never
seen i know some of you have been here
since the very early days but
let's be honest about it there's over
1500 videos on this channel alone not
even talking about how many videos there
are in the break room of geeks my
subsidiary channel or on vera wild which
is a whole other topic and that channel
is even older than this one but
there's a lot to talk about how we got
here
how have i spent the last few years how
did this happen
so i thought it'd be fun to talk about
the history of this channel how things
have changed the milestones the original
intent the swerves the unexpected the
highs the lows
and all that stuff
so
before we can even start
with what the channel was
i need to talk about what
it was originally conceived as because
the original original original
conception
spawned out of something that actually
predates
youtube
so in late 2004 i had just moved into an
apartment with a friend of mine from
college
and we
both huge massive geeks he'd uh made
like an independent film that i acted in
and you know we were in boston we were
kind of creatively hungry we also were
working crappy temp jobs uh initially
you know just to pay the rent
but um we had an idea
for what at the time we thought was
going to be
a full half-hour sitcom and at the time
we were just calling it geeks the series
that was the initial conception and it
was going to follow
three friends
two guys and a girl and they were just
gonna hang out talk about geeky things
there would be some of the somewhat
standard um
sitcom shenanigans you know they'd date
other people the plan was always for the
female character to be a lesbian so that
nobody would ever try and ship these
characters together um you know realize
this was like way back when i had
what i still thought was a straight cis
hetero conception so you know
the option for bisexual pairings or any
of that it didn't occur to either of us
i don't think at the time but in any
case
that was the idea and we actually
shot some scenes for that uh we we cast
someone he and i played the male
characters we cast someone else we shot
some scenes we never really had enough
to pull together a full episode
things changed i ended up moving out uh
unfortunately later on he and i had a
had something of a falling out
um but
what i had at the end of this and he he
like wrote the entire idea off um
like the last time that we kind of sat
down and talked with each other
like i've seen him randomly once since
then like just at a convention uh it was
a little awkward but it wasn't too bad
but he said you know what if you want to
do some new stuff do something with it i
don't care
so i had a handful of scenes i was
scrapping the stuff that was already
shot because i shot an apartment i
didn't live in anymore but i had a
handful of scenes that i kept mulling
over for a while so by this point we're
in about 2006 and i spent the next four
years after that living in new york and
while i was in new york i was mulling
this stuff over a bit more and around
that time youtube started to become a
thing i mean youtube was well launched
by them but like it was building steam
and it wasn't going away
now youtube at the time was not a place
to host long videos so i couldn't host
like a half hour sitcom but i also had
never had much luck framing this thing
as a half hour structured sitcom instead
i did have these handful of scenes and
i'd written some new ones since then
that were basically
two to five minutes
and i liked
but
they were just these disconnected little
scenes and i thought
you know
i could just shoot these as isolated
shorts
which i was never able to do when i
lived in new york i had neither the
means nor the time but then later after
moving up to vermont i started thinking
about this very very seriously
and
eventually saving up the money to get a
camera
get some editing software and get a
semi-decent microphone
i recast i still i was ultimately still
playing the same part but i i recast
with uh friends that i'd made since
moving up to vermont uh we have my
friend nathan culpitz as the other male
character and my friend nicole taylor uh
nicole bradford at the time uh they
they were playing the other parts and
we pulled it together and we started
shooting these now initially
i shot six of these uh in its original
state and i shot all of these before
editing and releasing
uh any of them and i had some
unreasonable ambition about this
thinking you know what it would be but
also i did have the rational part of my
brain saying this will probably not take
off this will probably not become a
thing but
you'll have gotten this itch
of like i still haven't done this just
off your back you'll scratch that itch
and it'll be done
so the very first video uploaded was a
super lame teaser
like incredibly lame teaser
embarrassingly lame teaser
and then after that was a slightly
better teaser and then the first episode
came out and that first episode i had
ambitions for that first episode that
first episode was supposed to be
one long continuous unbroken take
nathan could not memorize the entire
thing so
uh we had to break it up
a bit but we assembled like a whole
bunch of other friends that uh we made a
lot of them from the local community
theater most of whom would not appear
again partially just because i didn't
have that many extra parts but this was
shot uh in the house i was living in at
the time
and
uh we also we even had one shot on
location because there was like this
this i could make a whole other story
about this but
i wanted to shoot one in a video store
because there still were some around
here now i called one that was in my
town and the guy like he was willing to
shoot there but he basically wanted to
turn it into an overt advertisement for
his
uh for his location he wanted big
changes on the script because i have a i
had a fight break out he didn't want
that to happen and eventually just
became like this is ridiculous um so
then i called a an even smaller video
store next town over which is no longer
there anymore shock of shocks but they
actually let us shoot there after hours
and i
made all this up as i went
i
don't have formal training i don't have
an education i have a lot of passion but
i don't have an education in film and if
you watch these you can tell i don't
know how to color grade worth a dang i
don't know how to light and most of the
time that doesn't matter that much
because i shot during the day but i'll
tell you what the stuff shot that one
episode that i shot at night holy cow do
i wish i knew how to color grade back
then or how to light i because i also
didn't have a decent lighting setup i
had paint i had painters lights oh it
was bad but i was still kind of happy
with it
i thought the jokes bounced off well i
thought i got the rhythm of the editing
down pretty decently considering that i
barely knew what i was doing
i was kind of happy with it and i wanted
to do more and so i started scripting
more
but it was going to take a while for me
to write these get everyone together
shoot it edit it like it had taken a
while before i was like
the channel is going to seem dead
until i get another season of this stuff
out there
well that is what led to the first what
i called solo rant just me
rambling at the camera
and these were actually initially uh
scripted and relatively tight um they
became looser as time went on the very
first one went up in early 2013. and it
had the very click-baity title of how
final fantasy 7 ruined the final fantasy
franchise
and
it's a position that i actually don't
have a lot of problems with i don't look
back and go uh that was a bad take no i
get what i was saying it was a bit of a
click-baity title
but i had a few more after that and that
started to be something that i would do
on a regular basis because it was easy
and it became good filler content a
couple months after i started doing this
i would do my first doctor who video
ranking all of the doctors up to that
point now that is a video that would
prove to have some rather significant
legs which i guess it's worth mentioning
at this point
for someone who is able to make this
their living i've never had a video go
viral
now by most standards they consider a
million views to be viral honestly i
consider
500 000 to be
to be well viral um but i've never had a
video pop off like that i have a handful
of videos over 100 000 views but they've
all been slow burns they've all taken
months if not a year or more to crack
100k
so
it's it's interesting now because i can
look at the views on
that very first ranking the doctor's
video and it's got like 20 000 views and
i had like
a couple hundred subscribers at the time
but the thing is i know that 20 000 was
not immediate and youtube analytics
don't go back that far
but
i know that was a slow build
and i think that probably did encourage
me to bring back doctor who was a topic
now around that time i was doing about
one video per month on everything from
doctor who to comics superheroes in
general and i also got the uh second
season stuff starting to go out as well
now that was not performing as well so i
did kind of know that at this point this
the scripted stuff i'm doing because i
enjoy it and the instant i'm out of
ideas i might as well stop because it
takes forever and it's not what's
pulling in many views and understand at
this point like the channel it's this is
still this is a pastime this is
something i'm doing because it's fun
because i'm i've got no momentum to do
anything other than that but
my brain part of my brain still says do
it better do it bigger improve it
and so i would start experimenting with
different setups different backgrounds
doing things in different parts of the
house considering i couldn't light worth
a dang some of those look better than
others february of 2014 would mark the
very first appearance of the flat cap
though it would not become a staple of
the channel
until a bit later so for about the next
year from there i'm keeping up with
doing regular videos the second season
of stuff comes out in the summer of that
year i get my hands on a green screen
which i don't really know how to use and
only figured out how to use in the last
couple of years
but it stuck around off and on for a
while i start a sub series called
animation junkie which is basically just
an excuse for me to talk about animated
stuff that i don't have a reason to talk
about otherwise now also as we got into
2014 2015 i was really starting to pick
up the pace it was incredibly rare for a
week to go by without a new video upload
and sometimes they would come as
frequently as one every couple of days
though never for a sustained period of
time but i'm finding more momentum i'm
finding more things to talk about and
i'm creating more content around this
time new episodes of doctor who have
started airing the ones with peter
capaldi and those are starting to become
very reliable sources of views for me
getting for what was a big deal for me
at the time one to two thousand views
whereas the doctor who related lists
were getting in the tens of thousands on
a bit more of a slow burn the following
year in 2015 would see the very first
round table discussion that i had with
paul and ryan which of course brings us
to hey who are those other people who
are in uh your logo well
that's uh paul with the chest burster
and that is ryan with the lightsaber um
so the round table talks were something
that were a just a lot of fun to do and
that also became the initial launch of
the council of geeks podcast because
initially those were unedited uh
roundtable talks because you know i
would trim those up i would shorten
those um for the actual videos because
this was still back in the day before
youtube started to really favor
longer and longer and longer length
videos so i was still trying to edit for
time and keep things sub 10 minutes if i
could um or for the roundtable
discussions you know under 20. but then
i will put the unedited uh unedited
versions i can talk uh up as a podcast
and that was the initial council of
geeks podcast and not too long after
that i would launch 90s comics retrial
which was kind of the main feature of
the podcast for a while until i burnt
out on that a few years later i don't
want to keep diverting to the podcast
but like that's been a number of things
over the years that has been 90s comics
retrial that has been the extended
roundtable talks that has been go home
hollywood you're drunk which was a
really fun series i did with my friend
john van luling um but then logistics
got in the way of that then it was c
space cowboy then it was reviews of
classic doctor who and then it became uh
my working with jesse gender initially
with what the frel covering for escape
and currently with jump gate covering
babylon 5 and i have no idea what we'll
do next but we'll be on babylon 5 for a
while yet 2015 would also see the
release of the last of the scripted
shorts and i had said at the time that i
finished it up maybe if i come up with
another idea i really like we'll do
another one but that
that ultimately didn't happen and at
this point um
nicole uh has moved away she's no longer
local and i'm not living in the same
house anymore and i just haven't really
had the urge to go back to that kind of
scripted material and i feel like we
ended on a decent episode share my pain
puny mortal
oh
2015 would also see my very first
trailer reaction uh that one to the
trailer for the force awakens trailer
reactions were something that i would
start to dip in and out of but
ultimately uh they frequently would
become copyright issues so they were
never a main feature on this channel but
that's when they started in july of 2016
i moved into the house that i'm now in
and initially i set up shooting in a
real bad space uh the walls were super
echoey i was still trying to make the
green screen work all it does is pad the
runtime and it's just so full of itself
it infuriated me
it's real bad it's real bad those videos
are hard for me to watch i did not have
really the means to properly kind of
insulate the walls at all so it's echoey
it's terrible um it was the attic
is where like it's a finished addict
it's not like dirty and dusty but like
uh clusterflies would get in there
during the summer so it'd be these
things buzzing around my head yeah
i st i stuck it out there for a lot
longer than i should have bothered so by
december of 2016 i shot my first solo
rant out with
well not nearly as decked out but with
this shelf background and that was at
the time in my bedroom and that was for
a review of rogue one now i would still
there'd be a couple of random green
screen attempts that would show up after
that but pretty soon after i would ditch
the green screen except for one major
example a little bit later on and that
would become my main shooting area and
that actually stayed that way for quite
a while ultimately to my detriment i've
talked about this before but
it's not a good idea to
shoot
edit and sleep
in the same room it i i basically turned
my bedroom into a bit of a dorm room so
i would shoot
you know in front of this
i would then go over to the computer and
edit it sometimes you know at into very
early in the morning
and then go and crash in the bed and
because i turned a what should have been
a relaxing space into a workspace
anytime i was in my room
i couldn't relax if i tried to watch
something for fun or play a video game
or read or do anything like that part of
my brain was going you could be shooting
something right now you could be editing
something right now shooting setups
right there computers right there why
aren't you working so
it became a situation if i was in my own
room i was either working or sleeping
and that was it and i did that for
quite a while longer than i should have
also in december of 2016 i did my review
of the first fantastic beast film which
was the first piece of harry potter
related content on the channel which
would go on to be a semi-regular feature
right up until
yeah
we'll get there now 2017 was actually a
pretty big year and it kicked off really
really well
i don't know if it was partially because
i kind of accidentally i didn't mean to
but i accidentally from uh the 25th of
december 2016 through
january 4 2017 did a video a day and i
mean part of it was probably probably
the subject matter some of those were
reviews of the uh final season of
sherlock but you know this stuff
did quite well and it set me up for a
very strong 2017 definitely way stronger
than my years have been prior to that
2017 would see a lot of things happen it
would see the flat cap start to become a
staple
of the look and a little bit later that
year i would take a kind of deliberate
um
advantage of that because initially the
first introduction of the fly cap was
basically just
i didn't like my hair that day and i
didn't feel like dealing with it slapped
the cap on so i tried to get more solid
in my branding the cap became a fixture
uh in that year i also uh did my first
time i would say being deliberately
angry with my content like sometimes i
do get angry but i like to think i only
do so legitimately because i'm honestly
very upset
the this was the one time this was
talking about the dc eu and ranting that
it should die
and
i was frustrated i was annoyed it wasn't
completely manufactured you know this
was something i was genuinely irritated
about
however
i did
get shoutier than i felt and the video
actually did quite well partially as a
result of that but it also didn't feel
great it felt a little forced and so
pretty soon after that i kind of was
like i'm not don't force it yeah that
like if it happens it happens but don't
force it and i'm really happy for that
decision now later that same year i
started getting my first taste of fandom
blowbacks because there were snyder bros
who came at me when i was incredibly
skeptical of the uh initial justice
league trailer this was even before
joss whedon had taken over and uh also
uh surprisingly a lot of people really
came at me preemptively defending the
live-action ghost in the shell because i
was super skeptical based on trailers
and what we were hearing and a lot of
people came for me for that
boy did history bear out that they were
not correct to have preemptively
defended a movie they hadn't seen and
like i i feel in a lot of ways that has
given me a fair amount of comfort for
when i step on the wrong side of fandoms
uh right from one of my earliest times
of having that happen i i got i feel
pretty vindicated since then
that can give you a confidence boost it
helps so throughout that year in 2017
doctor who content is still consistently
my best performing stuff with occasional
spikes for comic book movie related
content as well i'm still doing the
round tables with paul and ryan but they
are consistently the worst performing
videos but i do them because i like
talking with these guys and like if
anybody's wondering the main reason that
it doesn't happen anymore is
we've all got kids like i already had a
kid uh you know when we started doing
this but now they both have kids and
like
life man logistics the logo i did
finally get done professionally later it
would go through some revisions
initially because i wanted a different
look for the queer focused videos when i
would do those um later adding in liz
when she started appearing never
dropping ryan or paul even though they
basically have not appeared on the
channel in person in years but i still
want them there they're a part of the
history i will keep having them there
and in 2020 the uh the artist for the
logo very generously did not charge
measured to do this updated liz's image
to get rid of the wand which was harry
potter inspired instead gave her
the infinity gauntlet which she wields
as she sees fit and i do not question
now in the tail end of 2017 i started
doing a video
a day and i would stick for that
throughout all of 2018
and part of the reason i was able to do
that is the thing that i talked about i
shot i edited i went to bed i kind of
lived in that room
and while i don't doubt that that was
probably a big contributor as to why
2018 was
one of if not my biggest growth years uh
in terms of the the channel really
finding momentum
it it's not a pace that it would be
healthy for me me to do and also like i
i like to think i do better quality work
now i mean the videos at that point
i will say that it helped me hone into
just the art of rambling which i got
very good at partially by necessity
because you know staying up late to edit
and comb through a video was
exhausting and something i couldn't
realistically do so i got very good at
turning on the camera you know thinking
a little bit in advance what do i want
to say but very good at turning on the
camera rambling for 10 to 12 minutes
and then just
slapping opening and ending credits on
it and uploading it if i could keep
talking continuously and not do anything
major not have a major pause or a major
flub or say something especially stupid
then editing time was real quick the
videos took longer to render than they
did to edit
and that's a big part of how i was able
to do that which again makes it hard for
me to go back and watch those because
they just seem
way less focused to me now but i am even
now damn impressed but even before that
streak really kicked off
uh 2017 as i said was a pretty good year
and i broke
10 000 subscribers that year so in
january of 2018 i did a q a
and
i took the opportunity to
come out as gender fluid to come out as
vera now i'd been out elsewhere in my
life i was out to friends i was out to
family
um but
uh i confirmed it there now part of the
reason was honestly
fear
because as i mentioned
earlier the vera wild channel is
actually older than this channel and
that
had been at 10 000 subscribers for a
little bit so with council of geeks
hitting 10 000 and having much better
momentum because uploads to the vero
wild channel were sporadic and not on a
regular basis
and so that wasn't growing in nearly the
same way and it never has but
i realized i have more subscribers now
to council of geeks than i have for vera
wilde which makes it increasingly likely
if i don't address this
that people will
who are here on council of geeks will
find somehow very wild and realize that
i'm the same person
and when i said that i was driven by
fear i didn't have a fear of being found
out because i have no shame or
embarrassment about my gender fluidity
or at the time um you know i i often
still thought of myself as a
cross-dresser or or disgusting myself in
those terms but the thing is
what i was afraid of
is if somebody else outs me first
and i respond to that
it looks like i was ashamed because
somebody said it before me
if i'm the one who says it
then nobody can say
that i am only owning up to it because
i'm embarrassed or
as some kind of pr move so
i shot that video i came out
i took the hat off because in the tail
end of 2017
i got
this hairstyle the short around here it
was longer at the top it was only like
to about here
but
i got that very deliberately so that i
could put the cap on and it would look
like a very short haircut but i would
have
this thing that i could grow out and
then i got that dyed actually it was
like a few days
bef like the day before i shot that 10k
video i got the color and for the first
time
and so i showed that
and i had that in the video
and i uploaded it and that was you know
the that was a big thing of what why
the cap became important beyond just
branding
because it was
it was a way to hide
but i had that at the tail end of the
10k video thinking only people who like
and support me will get this far into
the video i uploaded it and immediately
went to bed
because i knew otherwise i would stare
at it and stare at the comments
i woke up in the morning expecting to
have lost several hundred subscribers
drop back below 10k see a bunch of
people thr slinging nasty comments at me
and
none of those things happened
not a one of those things happened
the
furthest thing from support where some
people said
i don't get it but it doesn't really
matter to me
now granted at the time i also said i
don't think i'll ever be presenting on
this channel this way that
that clearly didn't hold true but it was
my thinking at the time i thought well i
have the vera wild channel to to look
that way but as
as
a more feminine appearance became not
a thing i did but rather just me
yeah things migrated over time so i
mentioned doing daily uploads i pretty
much managed that with only a couple of
hiccups through the entirety of 2018.
that streak held until march of 2019 and
even then it went to like sometimes it
was daily for stretch but then it would
go every couple of days but i just i
stopped forcing myself to do daily but
it was still pretty rapid fire and as i
said 2018 was my most rapid growth year
probably always will be in 2018 my
partner liz made her first appearance on
the channel where we both talked about
the black panther review 2018 saw me
talking about channel awesome basically
the only time that i have dabbled in
inter-channel drama
but it also kind of framed the way that
i talk about these kinds of things in
general when i talk about celebrities of
various natures generally talking not
about the initial actions but of what is
being done in the wake of people getting
upset what the pr response is
what's the conversation and that's kind
of always been the lens that i've gone
at these things with since then because
getting overly moralistic about um what
someone did or didn't do i'm not saying
that there isn't a moral value to
people's actions there is but i
generally find it much more interesting
and a little bit less fraught to talk
about the pr fallout
than about the things they did you do
need that information it contextualizes
but it's not where i want to put my
focus and that's kind of been true from
the start of me doing any of that kind
of content 2018 also saw my first
collaboration with another channel
working with stu bagful
work with around doctor who in
particular i had loved for a while up to
that point stu is great i love working
with him in may of 2018 would also see
my first tackling of an lgbtqia plus
representation topic when i went off
on what i considered to be a form of
queerbaiting where um studios or
directors or writers claim that there is
representation but it's not actually
there in the text and it's it's a phrase
sometimes referred to as word of god or
word of gay uh specifically basically
well the creators say that this
character's queer but you would not
necessarily know that just watching the
thing and i went off
and that is one of my it's like my
second best performing video now
i'm actually still quite proud of that
but that would kick off
what was for a time a monthly dedicated
video to lgbtqia plus representation
topics and i obviously still talk about
now it's just not fixed that definitely
once a month it's rather as i form new
ideas that i haven't already tackled
2018 would also see
joel my thumbnail guy joel johnson would
uh he what happened was he reached out
to me basically saying hey i love your
channel but your thumbnails kind of suck
uh would you be willing to let me try
doing them uh like for a week and
remember i was doing daily at the time
uh let me try doing your thumbnails for
like a week and if you like it would you
consider hiring me
to uh you know and pay me to do this for
you and yeah joel's been doing my
thumbnails ever since because he was
great in that week and i'm like yeah
you're hired and
um i would love to outsource more of
what i do i'd love to outsource
something like the editing but i can't
afford it but i do outsource the
thumbnails
because joel's so much better than that
i am i mentioned that i had gotten sort
of my first initial pushback from
fandoms a little bit before i got my
first taste of outright hate on a
sustained level uh from commenters in
2018 as well to uh to two things one my
nanette review where i praised that film
and that film kind of became a uh a
little bit of a lightning rod in and of
itself
and also my video uh tearing at scarlett
johansson for at the time accepting a
role of playing a trans man
and
yeah i went off on that i stand by how i
went off on that but part of that video
got featured on
uh on an
anti-sjw video from a channel that was
and still is
significantly larger than mine and so
the um
the fans of that channel descended on
mine
and made my life a little bit of a
nightmare in terms of clearing out the
comments for a while not the last time
something like that would happen but
that was my first taste of it
fun
since i'm doing daily video uploads you
know performance video to video varies
fairly wildly but consistently my best
performing videos were those on doctor
who those on queer topics and most of
the list type videos that i would do
because those tend to have longer legs
and they have more of a slow burn 2018
also saw the beginning of overdue doctor
who reviews where i went uh one episode
per week talking about episodes of
doctor who that i had not already done
reviews on because i started the very
first review that i did was for the day
of the doctor so i had all of eccleston
all of um dave attendance and almost all
of matt smith's run to do uh review
videos on so that started that uh in
2018 as well 2018 i also did the intros
contest somebody i cannot remember who
at this point and i feel really bad
about that uh somebody made me sort of a
marvel style intro that i used for a
while but i wanted uh something a little
bit updated making use of the logo so i
held a contest and i ended up with new
opening intros for the general topics
for doctor who specifically and also for
nitpick rants which i kind of want to
bring back if only to use this intro
some more because it's really good
why
in december of 2018 i did the very first
live stream those i actually did weekly
for a while which was another thing i
forgot that i'd done eventually those
would go bi-weekly within a year from
having started 2018 would also see me
rank third in the top 50 youtubers uh
poll that was done by sl studios the
following year i would come in at number
one and yeah i
have no shame in bragging about that i
also launched the patreon at the start
of 2018 as well
um so that's slowly building in tandem
start of 2019 january of that year i
finally get this camera so i have videos
that don't look awful though it would
take me a while to stop using the
autofocus sorry about that now february
2019 is when things they don't drop hard
but they start to slow down um basically
my better performing videos are still my
better performing videos but
how high things get is coming down and a
fair amount of stuff that isn't doctor
who or queer topics or
harry potter related or lists is coming
in uh a bit low for uh for what i was
usually getting throughout 2018. now
this slowdown i did notice it prior to
my easing off the daily video thing so i
think that was part of the reason
thinking back on it why i gave myself
permission to ease off the daily because
it wasn't seeming to be
just continuing to grow it was starting
to taper off whatever help that gave me
was easing off and so it became a matter
of
do you still truly are you really up for
doing daily and kind of accepting no
maybe i don't have to do that anymore
2019 would see my first attempt at
anything that could vaguely be called a
video essay um i did do some scripted
stuff particularly with the queer
content up to that point but
i wasn't really trying to structure it
like a video essay i wasn't trying to
emulate those kinds of things that were
becoming big i wasn't using a lot of
clips my review uh patreon sponsored
review for the first season of season of
titans would be the first time i would
start to really dabble in that and then
i would go full on really trying to
emulate that style and go in that
direction with my full overview of
cowboy bebop
it would not pay off in heavy views i'm
still quite proud of that video but did
not get viewed a lot and that actually
would end up holding true
most of the videos i'm proudest of
especially in terms of like how i put
them together the editing how it all
pulled together like the use of clips
and and all that
are usually not especially
well-performing videos i've just
accepted that at this point so sort of
leaping off from what i said about
things that aren't the main things that
i do
really getting lower and lower and lower
views i started to get concerned that
these are going to start dragging down
the channel but i don't want to start
suddenly stop doing things like just
reviews of tv shows that i've seen or
there's also the patron sponsored
reviews which are frequently a fairly
obscure stuff that the videos don't
perform well so in october of 2019 i
launched the break room of geeks the
subsidiary channel that's pretty much
all unscripted and is where the vast
majority of my basically any review
material that isn't uh something where i
think i have a grander point to make
like ended up being the case with my
sandman video last month or um
isn't doctor who because doctor who will
always be here on the main channel well
new episodes of doctor who anyway
classic reviews are in the break you get
what i mean that's what's there now and
initially it was set up to host let's
plays trailer reactions again because i
would freely frequently get copyright
claimed on those and also initially some
fan videos like some fan music videos
which i'm also quite proud of even
though like i can't monetize those
because of the music i put on them but
within a few months of the break room
being set up i start to put reviews for
older movies or tv shows that i don't
think are gonna play that well and the
patreon reviews start going there until
eventually most of the review material
goes there
2020
wasn't uh great in a lot of ways and not
just and even before like the pandemic
hit um for as far as the channel was
concerned it started out pretty weak uh
outside of doctor who stuff everything
else
was not performing especially well uh
off the bat i did get to go to gallifrey
one uh in 2020 that was a very good time
and then i came home and pretty much
everything immediately went into
lockdown april of that year i did one of
my favorite things that i've ever done
and it was actually thanks to joel my
thumbnail guy it was his idea to do an
april fool's video going over the
history of doctor who and playing it
completely straight and talking about
all the actors who played doctor who and
talking about all these american actors
in this american tv show he and i came
up with who would be and he did all
these photo shoppings of these different
actors
faces on various doctors it's it's still
it's still so fun
and it was great because because the
tone isn't jokey it
often took people like
it's interesting to see in the comments
how far into the video it was before
they realized what it was that i was
doing
uh that was a great idea joel i still
i'd like
if i still wore the flat cap i'd do a
hats off to you for that one later that
same month would see the very first
drunk review on the channel uh after i
watched cats in a group viewing
experience a you know remote group
viewing because lockdown and yeah we
drank our way through that and i rambled
drunkenly and if anyone's ever been to
the live
streams uh and has wondered why i end
those by going my cavity
uh the drunk cats review is why
so
check that out for context i guess
2020 would also see me no longer
defaulting to the flat cap for anything
that isn't a queer video the flat cap
will still show up and actually i'll
still even use it now intermittently
it's pretty rare but like if i feel like
it i'll wear it but that's the thing
up until that point for all of 2018 and
2019 it was basically if it's a queer
related topic flat cap comes off and i
show my hair everything else stays on
going into 2020 i said no
no we're we're not doing that wear it if
you feel like wearing it but if you
don't don't put it on
and
that's where it's gone since then and as
i said my own sense of self has
drifted more feminine over that stretch
of time and so it's appeared less and
less and less and less in may of 2020 i
moved down into my current shooting
location which is
i'm i just call it my office now which
is also where i've relocated my computer
so my bedroom is now just a room again
which is a lot better for me plus you
know i've got the sound going pretty
good in here i've got a decent lighting
setup that works and the very first
video that was shot
um in this location was a nitpick rants
video and i hadn't quite figured out the
lighting yet you can tell but
that's uh that's when i started shooting
in the current part of the house that i
still shoot in 2020 would see the final
attempt to try and resurrect 90s comics
retrial in video form i had done one
previously in my just a kind of rambly
style i think i did script it but um you
know it was not dissimilar to how say
linkara does his stuff but i went all in
i brought the green screen back i did a
whole courtroom setup and format
actually taking on the roles of a uh
defender and a prosecutor you know
making cases for or against the death of
superman um because i figured like if
i'm gonna do this i'd let me pick one of
the bigger things i've got sitting
around from the 90s and i poured a lot
into that and i said this is this
thing's last chance to be a thing this
is so much work and i'm really happy
with that video like but if this does
not take off then i'm walking away from
that project and it did not take off and
that will probably remain the last
episode of 90s comics free trial
in june of 2020 jk rowling
gives her turf manifesto now i had
already declared my conclusion that she
was transphobic december of the previous
year but that was the point at which it
was completely undeniable and it was
clear that she was not going to revise
or pull back from her positions anytime
soon so that marked the end
of harry potter-related content other
than occasionally discussing her in the
context of things like death of the
author
because
yeah
i can't and i won't
promote
anything related to her
part of me did consider privating or
taking down the harry potter related
content that is still on the channel
ultimately i left it up and just put a
pinned comment with a link to one of my
videos making it very clear that
not okay
super not okay
few other big things that happened in
2020 in july of that year i was laid off
so keep in mind i've been working a
full-time day job since before the
channel started so all through this even
when i was doing a video a day
that was on top of working a 40-hour
work week at a job that i increasingly
hated
i was laid off in july of that year and
when i announced it publicly i included
with that a request for people to
support my patreon in the hope
that i could get the bump to that
necessary to
make this my living
and amazingly it worked
it's
it's tight it was tight then it's still
tight now
if you are able to support me on the
patreon
uh like it
it still helps i still kind of need the
help no i still do need the help
but
the amount of support that i saw
that i got
it's what enables me to do this as my
job to make
content at the quality level that i'm
currently able to do it while honestly
able to do it at all because if this
wasn't my job i probably wouldn't have
been able to put the resources into
getting a computer uh when my laptop was
on death's door
at this point this channel exists
because
people stepped up and said yeah
we want to help ensure that you can keep
doing this
that's still amazing to me
a couple of other things that happened
in 2020 in september i
launched the kickstarter for my novel uh
dreams of fire
and uh and that was fully funded
by the end of the live stream fundraiser
that i did
which also blew me away
that was incredible
and also that same month in september
2020 i dropped the masculine pronoun and
just she they
that felt good to do 2021 would turn out
to be a year of discussing problematic
figures jk rowling would keep coming up
john barrowman no clark joss whedon
giana carano amber heard
and somewhat to my frustration most of
that stuff some of my best performing
things that year
and much like when i had pretty good
view numbers on that very first time i
did a deliberately angry rant it would
have been very easy or very tempting to
dip into harder into
celebrity drama basically i didn't
because there's a limit to how much i am
prepared or want or willing to talk
about this sort of stuff and i don't
want it to become what i'm known for
i'll talk about it when i have something
to say about it or if i feel like it
needs to be addressed but
i don't ever want that to be my focus
which makes it frustrating that it
performs as well as it did
2021 would also see basically the end of
non-doctor who review-related material
on the main channel because when my
uh godzilla vs kong and mortal kombat
reviews both tanked i figured you know
what the review material just other than
doctor who just isn't performing and
that's when pretty much everything went
over to the break room 2021 i would also
start using the shorts format which is
something youtube is still pushing i did
a whole video talking about why it's
kind of a nightmare to use that format
even though a lot of my shorts perform
well from a views
standpoint does not actually help me
because a lot of those views come from
people who clearly hate me
and obviously at this point i've dealt
with people who really don't like me
either because of something i said or
something that they think i am
or that they otherwise think about me
i've been dealing with that for years
now but
shorts shorts real bad
real real bad most people who hate me
seem to just avoid me short seems to
push me directly in front of people who
do not want to see me and will be
angered by it but like i said i talked
about that before throughout 2021 queer
topics continued to do well
comparatively to other content uh that i
have however um all of it is still down
from what it used to be with a couple of
random spikes like for instance uh the
one on queer youtubers coming out on
their channels that one did shockingly
well that video would more or less
directly go on to influence the
interviews that i did
with maelitz jxe jesse gender and james
stephanie sterling talking about their
experiences coming out after having
already built an audience that's another
video that i'm incredibly proud of the
format of which i would use again for a
video over on the vera wild channel
talking to a variety of creators on only
fans about their experience building
that as a platform after already having
built uh followings elsewhere that one's
even longer and i'm even prouder of that
that's on the vera wild channel if you
haven't checked it out
some other videos that i'm especially
proud of many of which have
underperformed by number standards but
stuff that i've
really i'm really genuinely still proud
of include how to fix ghostbusters 2
girl fight about the patterns of how
women are depicted in action scenes and
movies a video from earlier this year on
the depiction of consent and my
breakdown of why the watchman movie
fails in adaptation by being too loyal
to a source material i'm actually
incredibly proud of that one overall as
we hit the tail end of 2022
it's a lot like 2021 as far as the
trends and algorithms go celebrity drama
is still some of my best performing
stuff doctor who never stopped being a
staple of the channel and it never will
be but we have reached a period where it
only performs well when there is new
stuff dropping be it episodes trailers
or major news uh bits coming out when
none of that is going on things like the
take two reviews which are on pause but
will resume again
don't perform especially well i don't
know how much of that is just um a
declined interest in the property under
chibnall's uh regime
possibly i don't know we'll see if
things pick up overall with uh rtd
taking over again i'm not gonna stop
talking about doctor who either way
just would be nice if the numbers would
get better again uh speaking of doctor
who related earlier this year i went to
gallifrey one again and i met uh jason
hey gallery who is the executive
director of big finish and i got to sit
down and have a talk with him that's
another video that i'm quite proud of
simply because the dude recognized me
at
california it was his suggestion that we
talk
so
yeah
a lot of highs
there have been dips there have been
lows uh at least as far as videos go but
also sometimes in terms of reception or
you know getting on the wrong side of an
audience occasionally finding out that
there's a very rabid audience that i
didn't realize existed that now hates me
that has happened with things like
inside number nine and the movie in
bruges but for the most part
these 10 years
have been amazing
i got to start out as an outlet for
creative energies that i needed to get
out
and then just became
a way for me to ramble about geeky stuff
when maybe i had thoughts to get out
that
i may not have had anybody else to talk
to them about
and then
to just keep doing that
because i liked it it was fun
to sit and talk with my friends and to
experiment with formats and to try
talking about new things and to have the
bonkers idea of doing a video a day and
doing that for a year
to doing this way too much to scaling
back to getting to do it for my living
to finding a better work-life balance
which is something i'm still working on
but
seeing the quality of what i do get
better so i'm happier prouder of things
that i do
and to have this be my living
this has been an amazing 10 years
and i credit a fair amount of this to
you know not having burned out even when
i was doing a video today because i
won't talk about stuff i don't care
about
i was i went through a stretch where i
was able to find a topic a day to do it
but
i
do this because i love it
and
the numbers tempting sometimes
it was tempting to look at the numbers
think i should do more celebrity drama
it performs well i should be angrier it
performs well
but i'm really proud of myself for not
ever really seriously dipping into that
for the sake of better viewing numbers
because for as long as i've been doing
this channel should be bigger honestly
and anybody who is in analytics hound
could have looked at what i was doing
looked at how i was performing and could
have told me exactly what i could have
done to get
higher numbers maybe get to do this
professionally sooner than i was but i
wouldn't have been doing it the way i
wanted it
it was more important for me to grow
this slowly and have it still be
something that i love
because it's still
something that i
love
doing
it's been a great 10 years
here's to the next 10
and beyond
thank you very much for watching
what has been your favorite
bit of nonsense i've done in the last 10
years or
top five or whatever you want to do it's
a lot of stuff like i said about over
1500 videos you can drop something down
in the comments and we'll talk about it
like share subscribe i imagine this is
mostly people who are already subscribed
but even if you're new hey there's a
catching you up on everything if you're
able to support me on my patreon i
mentioned it before that's of great help
but no matter what
if you are this far into this video
what i really need you to know
is you are beautiful
you are valid
you are loved and in a phrase
first brought up and suggested by a
commenter
as a possible answer for why this was
still called council of geeks even
though that was a name that originated
because it was a short about a group of
people and i initially had the round
tables to have a group and have a
council and that hasn't been the case in
a while
a commenter suggested oh but we're all
the council
and i've taken that and run with it and
so yes
you are the council
i just run the meetings
and until next time
for as long as i can keep this going
this council
is adjourned
[Music]
time to give my thanks to my highest
supporting patrons that would include
robin moore zubin lutfullah tarak the
thing that goes doink in the anime
oliver b melinda walters imudelki the
other boy becky sparks fernandi likes
the poodle zach idolin tracy scrabbit
angry casper adam rdl taylor shane ross
shaylee gourley brandon larose and tt
[Music]
if you want your name said while these
guys try and distract me
consider looking at the rewards of my
patreon
[Music]
um
[Music]